hey Siri yes what's the difference
between plot and story our story and
plot the same thing I don't know it's a
good question should we ask Siri I had
thought of that the test let's try it
what's right I don't know okay hey Siri
yes what's the difference between plot
and story what's the difference between
plot and story all right let's see oh
great the difference between plot and
story did jurors have more of like a
British accent
yeah oh I like the I like the British
lady she makes me feel that's cool
classier the King's English a story is
the requisite timeline of events present
in any narrative no story no novel
because any novel however abstract must
report events of some kind a plot
express his rationale and informs the
reader why a specific list of events
belongs together what the timeline is
ultimately meant to communicate so yes
they are different Thank You Siri it
only took an eternity so yeah do you
think of that when you're writing or no
none of that enters your mind it's not
you no not okay not a single iota no I
just try to think what's cool
what can be cool and then who could be
cool and then what can they get into
and then how about that extrapolates
into other stuff I learned what is it
called
I think it's called the law of
inevitability and this was taught to me
by David greenwalt
who I think got it from Joss Whedon so
basically what the law of inevitability
means is if this happens inevitably this
will happen
and then if that happens and never to
believe that what happened and then if
that happens and never to believe that
will happen that's kind of the rule I
can use I just kind of go and then it
becomes this really sort of organic
process cuz like I said before I don't
do all the stuff I don't do the outline
and the thing and the thing and the
cards in the pen do any of that I just
sort of like to investigate the
characters through the story and then
alright here's this scenario okay so now
that that happen what would she do well
she would probably do this because of
Adam but if she does that he's probably
gonna do this that's how I do it did you
always feel you had your own voice no I
swear I didn't know no wasn't until I am
awed Lee you know left the city and just
started to not try to follow the track
because you know there's like a track
there's like always like the hot thing
that's happening in town right and so
everybody's trying to come up with their
version of that thing and then when I
stop trying to do that I just started
figuring out what I liked even movies
and TV shows and stuff like you know
what I like that's when
like The Voice kicked in like that
smells like okay well you got a
definitive opinion about this in society
and so then that creeps in
you
what do you do what do you hit a thing
think you hit a thing well yeah this is
ridiculous Siri Siri nothing no I didn't
do it
I don't know can't even figure out Siri
not it's like a it's the at school it's
the phone it's the X phone so I'm going
to send more run go into you know
general or settings and I guess so I
never use it either totally gonna field
day with this we can we can fast for
somebody this is more I can't even
figure out here well we'll probably just
have you pick up the phone and then cut
from there
oh okay for for time sake it might be
kind of funny to have a little bit of my
nonsense maybe do like a snippet in the
beginning and then do a kind of funny
thing kind of fun listen for hey Siri
press oppress side button for Siri okay
there we go
but side button this one ah there we go
hey Siri sorry hey Siri didn't work oh
hey how you doing um is there a hello
Siri is there a difference between story
and plot oh she totally went away hey
Siri yes what's the difference between
plot and story